this video is about single fact analysis
of variance with repeated measures
and we start right away with the first
question what is repeated measures
analysis of variance
repeated measures analysis of variance
tests whether there are statistically
significant differences among three or
more dependent samples
so what are dependent samples
in a dependent sample the measured
values are linked for example if a
sample is drawn of people who have a
knee surgery if these people are asked
before the surgery and one week and two
weeks after the surgery we call it a
dependent sample this is the case
because the same person was surveyed at
several points in time therefore the one
factor analysis of variance with
repeated measures is the extension of
the t-test for dependent samples for
more than two groups
in the t-test for dependent samples we
test whether there is a difference
between two dependent groups if we want
to test whether there is a difference
between more than two dependent groups
we use the analysis of variance with
repeated measures
when there are three or more independent
samples analysis of variance without
repeated measures is used
if you want to know more about it feel
free to watch my video for analysis of
variance without repeated measures but
be careful of course the assumptions
have to be checked first more about this
later
so what is the research question in a
repeated measures analysis of variance
the research question could be
is there a significant difference
between the dependent groups in terms of
the mean
but let's look at an example now
you might be interested to know whether
a therapy after a slipped disc has an
influence on the patient's perception of
pain
for this purpose you measure the pain
perception before the therapy
in the middle of the therapy and at the
end of the therapy
now you want to know if there is a
difference between the points in time
so in this case your independent
variable is time or therapy progressing
over time your dependent variable is the
pain perception
you now have a history of the pain
perception of each person over time
and now you want to know whether the
therapy has an influence on the pain
perception or not
simplified in the first case the therapy
has an influence and in the second case
the therapy has no influence on the pain
perception
in the progression of time
the pain perception does not change here
in this case it does
now we have a good transition to the
hypotheses
in the analysis of variance with
repeated measures the null hypothesis is
there are no significant differences
between the dependent groups
and the alternative hypothesis is there
is a significant difference between the
dependent groups
this brings us to the assumption of
analysis of variance with repeated
measures and finally i will show you how
you can easily calculate it online
so what are the assumptions
the first assumption is that we must
have dependent samples the next
assumption is that the data should be
approximately normally distributed and
should have a matrix scale level
and finally the variance in each group
should be equal
now i will show you how you can easily
calculate an analysis of variance with
repeated measures online
just visit the statistics calculator on
datadeb.net and copy your own data into
the table here
then you click on this tab
now i just have to select your variables
if you select three or more metric
variables an analysis of variance with
repeated measures will be calculated
automatically
and you get the results
here you can read the p-value
if you don't know exactly how to
interpret the results just read the
interpretation of the results in words
in addition the results are shown in a
box plot
finally the bonferroni posthoc test is
calculated
i hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next time